on se souvient que pendant son procès en
1977 Patrick Henry n'avait sauvé sa tête
que grâce à l'intervention de ses
avocats dont maître Robert Badinter il
avait fait Robert Badinter de ce procès
un vrai plaidoyer contre la peine de
mort et les jurés l'avaient suivi
aujourd'hui encore Robert Badinter
interrogé par yasminber se souvient
j'aiis libération
conditionnelle je me suis
souvenu de ses dernières paroles à la
cour d'assise
le président venait de lire la décision
stupéfaction une émotion
immense tous croyai ou presque que il
sera condamné à mort donc fait qu'il n
pas été suscité des mouvements passionné
puis l'ordre s'est
rétabli le président lui a dit Patrick
Henri la Cour a fait preuve à votre
égard d'une grande
[Musique]
mensuétude souvenez-vousen et soyez en
digne et Patrick Henry qui av beaucoup
de mal à
parler a dit en réponse une voix blanche
encore je vous remercie je n'aurz pas
regretter et c'est cet engagement là je
pense qu'il a tenu au long du quart de
siècle écoulé et c'est ça qui am la
libération conditionnelle il a tenu sa
parole